vous allez tous être beaux pour vous nourrir d'Amazon ou de la
qualité de Monsieur entre
OpenSocial et Jody façon oui façon Bjelica l'homme est
ridicule sur la foire à la gélatine Oh continu
je vais prendre le long regard qu'elle s'est levé
sur le dos et nous disons garder ça s'oppose
[Musique]
ça  est toujours dit oui ou plus grand il
y en aurait il y en a saviez-vous
le plus faux qu'est-ce qu'il est du Nevada
Jessica est venu maire que les PHA peuvent faire le
plus récent rejeté terriblement Jeff ajouter plus
il y avait un méga méga à mon Minogue hors
Steve une logique Mempa  inclure la pieuvre
Brujo un chaman
voir Sudoku sociogramme hydrophobe Corée
pour débarquer un Shiva Asie moderne plan de
mis llaves partes que la Movida Trevis
Austin una Estrella Mountain ocarinas
le Moapa Jamaïque Bragance
apparente entrer dans l'offre d'œstrogène
aujourd'hui sur une zone abyssale d'étang
quand un mutant se désintègre très  sérieusement
[Musique]
restez à l'écoute revu message
Ciccone nouveau velum fatalité vraiment de cette
façon
- scooch sur Google assez tapageur
million de dollars comme un stock vous boutonnez à
nouveau
je suis  fou
suka kami obtenir plus il était sur le point d'être
conseillé de vomir
si Allah cliquez sur supprimer mo kamo voir la
lave se préparer G sait déjà aucune
panique
Anuj apprenti oreillette dépression ou
perte nous Syrie
[Applaudissements]
Ponyboy
je ne peux pas sortir de mon
[Musique]
que des pommes de terre importante Nani
photosynthèse on ne connait que le
jubilé d'argent en Toyota Corolla
[Musique]
qu'as-tu fait ce week-end Ayanna moi
rien de très intéressant le monde
reste en deuil après la mort
du Superman on pose sur ces inspecteur
ces animaux montanans et  où est le
retour de Gotham, le mappeur Delaney a été
un no-show,
ils ont dit l'âge des héros qui ne
reviennent jamais
vite  ]
regardez Tommy
[Music]
que nous vivons pour
le cobia c'est l'époque où
les plus grandes préoccupations des mamans explosaient les
pingouins à remonter c'est
fou notre organe de naissance meurt
chacun de nous d'une manière ou d'une autre est retenu
ne s'engage pas  e seul Little Miss ensemble
vraiment cool vous les gars prêts à se battre
détendez-vous Alfred je vais le prendre à partir d'ici euh
je sais que vous
Superman était un phare pour le monde
il n'a pas seulement sauvé les gens vous pouvez voir
les meilleures parties de lui-même
je  ne reconnaissez pas bien nous devrons
reconnaître que
vous auriez dû rester
[Musique]
combien d'entre vous n'êtes pas assez nombreux vous
pensez vraiment que c'est oh wow ils ont
juste vraiment disparu
oh soyons impolis
[Musique]
vous avez dit que vous le feriez  viens maintenant espérons que
tu n'es pas trop en retard on doit faire ça engageons-nous
l'heure de minuit est proche des
créatures rampent à la recherche de sang pour
terroriser le voisinage de vous tous seront
trouvés n'aimez-vous pas
Dandan prenez les chiens de l'enfer et pourrissez à l'
intérieur d'une carapace de cadavres
pas moi
tout le monde
[Musique]
attendez
vous
ple  ass donne m'en quelques
je suis
en 2045 il n'y a plus nulle part où aller
sauf l'Oasis
[Musique]
Je suis né en 2025 mais j'aimerais avoir grandi
dans les années 1980 comme tous mes héros je vis
ici à Columbus Ohio et 2045 qui est
toujours classé  la ville à la croissance la plus rapide sur
terre, mais cela ne semble certainement pas être le cas lorsque
vous vivez dans les piles
qu'ils ont appelées notre génération que de manquer des
millions manquants non pas parce que nous sommes allés
n'importe où, il n'y a plus rien pour aller
nulle part sauf l'Oasis
le seul endroit qui ressemble à moi  signifie
n'importe quoi dans
le monde où les limites de la réalité
sont votre propre imagination
[Musique]
Je m'inquiète des moyens que j'en vois si délicieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
tant de choses se sont passées  depuis que je t'ai vu j'ai
perdu mon marteau comme hier donc c'est
encore assez frais
alors j'ai fait un voyage de
découverte de soi je t'ai rencontré
là
et toi et moi nous sommes disputés hier soir
[Musique]
maintenant je veux e  asily sound right Oh
[Music]
oh dieu est mort nous allons renaître à Miami
Je pensais que tu serais content de me voir
tu viens d'apparaître ici et maintenant empêcher
Ragnarok la fin de tout commencer
à constituer une équipe
comme la surprise du bon vieux temps
Le père de Dibley Scott
[Musique]
salut
soit un
combattant on y va
je ne suis ni une reine ni un monstre
je suis la déesse de la mort
qu'est-ce que tu étais encore le dieu
[musique]
nous sommes les mêmes unis juste quelques
imbéciles à tête brûlée
oui  dire toutes les portes coupe-feu rapides comme l'
eau sur un peu comme le feu le tout
comme le feu qui fait rage - j'aime le
feu qui couve
le truc avec la guerre c'est que ça n'a fonctionné que des
deux côtés je crois qu'ils sont les bons gars
la vérité est que nous ne sommes pas si différents nous
battez-vous pour récupérer ce qui était autrefois notre
mais à la fin tout et c'est la fin
c'est juste une ville où vous vous habituerez à les
regarder tomber comme si nous étions en sécurité pour l'
instant nous devons déterminer notre prochain vote
donc ce n'est pas le prochain  bouge et il n'y a aucun
moyen qu'est-ce que
nous ne sommes pas ici pour manger ces ports non je suis
une crevette oh th  est-ce que le gars a du porc dieu
tu es arrogant
je ne cherche pas de super traits je
[la musique]
n'a pas d'importance je ne peux pas combattre ces
gens même avec ce que ta main
peut faire c'est bon marché
ce n'est pas leur chasse aux amis ou
famille et je ne vais pas m'arrêter là
[Musique]
plus de mort arrive
la seule chose qui garde Manhattan du
Kremlin à un tas de poussière
vous quatre les guerres sont à New York c'est fini
pas encore
[Musique]
cinq ans de rapports
je peux  tu vois tu as formé une sorte d'étang
en promettant avec une aura temporaire ils
vont te décevoir